ん
[音楽]
あった
ウールんだ
tee
皆さんこんにちは改めまして2010のミス日本グランプリの鷹打者をと申します
今日は皆さんに私がミス日本通じて学んだ
2つのことをぜひオフしできればと思いきました
しかしまずはじめになぜ私がミス日本コンテストに出場したのかそのことをまず知って
頂くために1枚の写真を見てもらいます15歳の時の私です
私は幼い頃からずっと走ることが本当に大好きでした
鈴のついたランドスレを背負っていつも陶芸家をしていたのでよく近所の人からは
あなたが帰ってくる時間が空に9時間
近所の人みんな知ってるよよく言われました
中学生の時にはジュニアオリンピックという舞台を経験しました
前の選手が走っている姿を見て横浜の大きなスタジアムで大歓声を受けて走ること
どんなに楽しいんだろう
国も気持ちが高ぶっていたことを今でも覚えています
しかし結果は予選乙でした
悔し涙をこらえながらでもせっかく横浜に来たから中華街って美味しい小籠包を食べて
帰りました
そんなにが来て悔しくてでもちょっとおいしい経験もあって
もっと高校では強くなろう日本一になろう
そう思って陸上部の門を叩きました
しかし1カ月後
私は突然走れなくなりました
歩くことすらも難しくなりました
原因は腰椎を2本折る疲労骨折でした
大好きなものがなくなって本当に毎日落ち込んでいたんですけども
陸上部の監督が常に励ましてくれて一年後リハビリを乗り越えてようやく復帰すること
ができました
しかし最後まで中学生の記録すら抜けず
卒業してより良い先生に恩返しできなくてすみません
そうあまりに行きましたすると先生はこんな言葉を返してくれました
先生に恩返ししようとしなくていい
でもお前はこれから社会に出て誰かの役に立って誰かをよエロコバせる
そんな姿を見せてくれることが先生のとっては
一番の恩返しなやべっ
私はこの言葉を深く心に刻み
大学生になってからはイギリスへ語学留学に行ったり
これはちょうど休日に訪れた
湖水地方ピーターラビットが舞いところなんですけれども
そうやって語学を勉強しに行ったり
熊本大震災が起こった時には復興支援のボランティアに参加したり自分が出来ること
チャンスがあれば何でも飛び込んで行ってきました
そして昨年ドイツへの長期留学に申請しました
留学先の大学も決まりいよいよ奨学金
住む場所そういう話がすまっ詰まっ詰めていく中でどうしても一つ引っかかることが
ありました
それは
何のために留学するのだろう
その明確な目的が最後まで見つかりませんでした
このまま何となく留学して社会人になるよりも
自分はもっといますんで日本のことをその文化社会を学びたい
しかも大学の講義じゃなくて実体験を通じて肌でそれを感じたい
そう思うようになりましたそれからは毎日図書館行ったり本屋さん行ったり
インターネット当たったりそんなプログラムがないか本当に毎日探しました
なかなか思うものには目暮会えなくてまあとりあえず留学へ行けば
何か道が開けるかな
そう思ったときにあるひとつのホームページにたどり着きました
それこそがミス日本コンテストでした
そのホームページで見たのは書類審査面接審査
そして地区大会を通過するとファイナリストに選ばれます
そのファイナリストでは
4か月間にわたって計30以上の講座
それを全部日本に関する外交であったり歴史政治
全校芸能
リベラルアーツのように勉強ができる
しかもその先生はそれぞれの分野でまさには活躍されている方々です
そしてミス日本を受賞するとそこから1年間
国内外での社会貢献活動をはじめ文化スポーツ
多様な活動ができ自分自身が成長できる場が与えられるということを知りました
私はこれまでコンテストと言うと何かこう
熾烈な勝負の世界というイメージがありました
でも学べる成長のためのコンテストなら私にも挑戦できるんじゃないか
そう思い始めました
そして最後私の決断は同市してくれたものには大好きな読書があります
私はとにかく幼い頃から本読むのが好きでした
中でも偉人の伝記これが好きで本当に新しい神の電気が
出ないかな毎日のように図書館本屋さんに貼っていたぐらい
それくらい楽しみにしていたものが
電気でした
今そんな歴史上の人物に会って直接話はできないけれどもこの勉強会に参加できれば今
活躍してる未来の偉人に直接話ができる
もうどうせダメでもともとなんだからやるだけやってみよう
そう思って横暴決意しました
ちょうど締め切りの2日前だったので急いで郵便局に駆け込みました
本当に運よく私はファイナリスト13人に残ることができてそこから始まった勉強会と
いうのはもうほんとに楽しくて楽しくて仕方ありませんでした
これは国際的な技でプロトコールを学ぶ授業です
国際的な式典首脳部が出席するような式典では国旗をこのように置くんですよ
ちょうどそういうことを教えてもらっている場面です
他にも納刀してした方というものを教わったり
世界に誇る日本史という講義もありました
私はこれまで歴史といえば過去に起こったことを理解する
そういう歴史を学んできた
ように感じていましたでもここで学んだのは未来へと続く
生きている歴史でした
どういうことかというと例えばじゃよく最近ニュースでも耳にする皇室というワードに
関して
私がこれまで知ってた知識というのは南北朝動乱であったりちょっとマイナーなものだ
と宇佐八幡新作事件
いずれも過去に起こった校講師の存続の根幹を揺るがすようなそんな過去も出来事
ばかりでした
でも先生がここで教えてくれたのは日本社会と皇室の具体的なこれまでの結びつき
そして彗星自らが今そのつあり方皇室はどのようにあるべきか
中枢で議論されているというそういう話を聞いたときに私はこれまでニュースを聞いて
もちょっとピンと来なかったのが
もしかしたら今歴史の転換期を目にしているのかもしれない
そういう実感が湧いてきました
茶道もそうです日本史同様一つ一つのコマから知識を学んだのではありません
ここで学んだのは生きているものを山を心
相手をもてなす心でした
例えば出されるお茶も2つとして同じものはないし
このお茶を点てる指図という空間自体が掛け軸いけばらすべての細部に至るまで季節で
あったり
客に合わせて考えられています
そして全ての講義が終わった時に私は一つ一つの講義がパズルのようになって一つの
メッセージを伝えてくれている
そんな実感がありました
そのメッセージとは
日本人らしいとです
言い換えるならはの心だと思います
でもその言葉では少し漠然としているので一番身近な言葉に置き換えるとそれは
相手を想うことだと感じます
相手とは必ずしも今を生きる人に限定されず
これまで歴史を築いてくれと新人であっぱり
周りなる自然でやっぱり
様々なものを思う気持ちというのはこれまでずっと大切にされてきた
和の心ではないでしょうか
私はミス日本コンテストを通じて勝つことではなくて
この相手を想うことを学びました
陸上では同じスタートラインに立っていを挑んで一斉にスタートします
でもここにいる私以外
12人のファイナリストがいたんですけれども皆
スタート地点はいろいろでこれまでの歩みも本当に様々
彩り豊かでした
そこに関して決して勝ち負けはないし
私がこうやっていいのミス日本として活動させてもらっているのも本当にご縁なのだと
思っています
実際私はファイナリスト期間中自分のことだけで構成いっぱいなりそうなこと何回
まいりました
でもその度にふと顔を上げるとこの素敵な
12みんな仲間がマイのことを第一に考えて行動しているその姿を見て本当に反省をし
てきました
今でも続いています
今でもしかも大切な仲間です
私は今ほんとにたくさんの失敗や反省を重ねながらもこの
相手を想うこと学んでいます
この場にどんな貢献ができるか
この活動で相手の方にどうすれば喜んでもらえるか
そのことを考えながら活動しています
でもそれだけじゃ足らないそう思うようにもなりました
ミス日本とはこうあるべきなんじゃないかそんな考え方にとらわれて求められたこと
しかできない
そんなことが何回も何回もありましたでもそれが必ずしも相手の為になっているとは
限らない
自分らしさが出せて自分自身が楽しめて初めて
今日すごい達成感があったな相手の方に喜んでもらえただろうな
そう思えることに気づいたのです
そこで私が考える次なるステップはこうです
自分らしさを加えていくこと
陸上の挫折そして先生かけてもらった言葉辛いライター
社会の役に立ちたいという漠然とした夢も
自分らしく一つ一つ行動していくことの先に具体的な実現があると信じています
相手思うその中に自分らしさを加えていくこと
このバランスこそが私の理想とするはですありがとうございました
[拍手]
プーペ